[Music]
we bring in carson palmer former nfl
quarterback heisman trophy winner at usc
where do you want to start
what's uh what's the headline here for
you today
i get to pick the topic
yes
uh
let's talk about that that shirt you got
on what year did you purchase that shirt
um it's actually one of those
new shirts that look old
i like it i like it do you have a
stylist uh no
i don't know no just maybe i'm natural
yeah okay that's all i want to talk
about i don't really have much else all
right nice to talk to you again carson
we appreciate you joining us here um
did you ever have anything like russell
wilson had
an injury like that
i did um
my second to last year playing we were
in philadelphia
we had the number two seed pretty much
wrapped up in in the nfc and we were up
on philly late in the game and i went to
throw a ball
and it was a sunday night football game
and my this finger
went up and backwards and was stacked
this portion of my finger was stacked
back here i dislocated
ligaments or dislocated the knuckle on
the joint and tore ligaments
did not require surgery out it was we
were about to start the playoffs the
next week so we just taped it up and
went from there but
it's hard to throw when your fingers
don't work and watching russell throw
the other day he didn't have velocity he
didn't have the same whip on the ball he
normally has he doesn't have the
strength in his hands back that'll come
that's not something that that he's lost
forever that'll come back but it was
hard to watch him play when you don't
have the full use of your throwing hand
and you're throwing fingers it just
makes for a long day like it was
yesterday in green bay for russ if they
don't make the playoffs carson if you're
russ
what do you want and if you're pete
carroll and the seahawks what do you
want to do
well if you're pete you want another
shot and you want to keep keep trying
and keep going with russ if you're russ
you don't know what's what's going on in
russ's head right now we all all we know
is he was unhappy last offseason there
was some talk about a trade there was
some talk about more more control more
personnel decisions
so we don't know what has is going to
transpire this off season
but obviously if you're pete you want to
continue to coach i mean he don't want
to go and start over and and start
his program somewhere else with a new
team and have to you know start from
scratch again he wants to keep going
russ on the other hand uh we already
know there was some unhappiness last
year sitting at i think three and six
right now there's going to be more
unhappiness that that division got great
right before our eyes i mean you looked
at what what uh the rams have done the
last couple weeks with obj with von
miller you look at what's going on in
arizona arizona's leading the division
and and really now for the first time in
russell's career he's sitting in third
place in the nfc west looking up at
those two teams and that's a tough spot
to see
to see what he's thinking right now but
we're going to know a lot by the end of
the season adam schefter reporting an
mri revealed that the packers running
back aaron jones has a mild mcl sprain
expected to be out one to two weeks i
thought what was interesting is the
defense with the packers you know we
always talk about aaron rodgers in the
offense but the defense actually looked
good against kansas city the previous
week they might be a top five defense
they don't even have you know two of
their maybe their two best defensive
players here and
i mean that's
that might separate the packers from
everybody else in the nfc uh your
thoughts on on green bay as a as a
complete team i i need to see more
consistency out of the defense i mean
sometimes that defense like yesterday
looks great against the 60 russell
wilson three weeks ago they looked
terrible and and kevin king the corner
from the university of washington has
looked like he struggled early on the
year and then yesterday he looks great
makes an interception is making plays
um you know blocking and knocking down
passes so it's just it's it's really an
inconsistency issue in green bay i mean
sometimes they look great and they shut
out uh you know the seahawks for the
first time in decades and then other
times
they look like they're running around
with their heads cut off and they're not
getting pressure on the quarterback and
they're not covering down on the back
end so it's just really consistency we
need to see it you know three four five
weeks in a row before we say they're the
most complete team in the nfc
kansas city feels like there's nothing
to see after they blow out the raiders
and everybody is fine and back on the
bandwagon here
should they be should they have gotten
off the bandwagon and should they be
allowed back on the bandwagon if that's
the case cars
you can jump off the bandwagon after
three or four weeks five weeks in a row
that we saw kansas city really struggle
but when you have tyron mathew on the
back end of the defense when you have
patrick mahomes on the front end and
tyree kill and all the players they have
you know they're always going to be a
contender for the first time this season
we actually saw
patrick mahomes not try to just put the
team on his shoulders and make amazing
throws and do something spectacular
every couple drives for the first time
he just took what they gave him he was
throwing the ball deep when he had the
opportunities and they were there and
then he was taking the ball and checking
it down they stuck with the run game
this is kind of the breakout game that
we've all been waiting for in kansas
city we've been waiting for them just to
jump out and pound somebody now the fact
that they did it on national television
against a good raiders football team
inner division game which those games
are always a fight and and to see them
come in and just absolutely dominate the
game it's like finally and finally the
kansas city fan base we're back now
we're ready this is the time if you're a
kansas city fan that you want to see
this team start putting it together and
go on a run
how do you go from your couch to the end
zone if you're cam newton
well there aren't many built like cam i
mean that that is a physical specimen if
anybody can do it it's him um obviously
he gets in and scores two early
touchdowns in his first two touches um
but this is a different offense though
nick carson that what he ran when he was
there before so you got to come in and
sort of get acclimated up to speed
terminology in a couple of days
yeah i mean there were some limited
snaps for him and and really his
specialty is you get down inside the red
zone inside the 10 yard line he's almost
virtually
impossible to stop and so i really like
the dynamic that they have they're
really good on defense they're salty up
front in the defensive front uh they can
cover on the back end with the addition
of stephen gilmore and and now if you
can sprinkle in some cam on third and
shorts down in the red zone use sam
darnold be you know be a little bit
unexpected defensively you don't know
when you're gonna get cam sometimes on
third down sometimes on first and ten
and then you know you gotta deal with
them in the red zone that's a that for a
defensive opponent's standpoint that is
a nightmare to prepare for that is a ton
of time on task sitting in meetings that
is a ton of practice on the field the
speed auction uh all the different
things you can do with cam in the back
field i really like the dynamic i i like
to see how this is going to work over
the end of the season and i wonder could
he get to a total of rushing touchdowns
that would put him sort of on the
periphery of a hall of famer had the mvp
went to a super bowl
and i wonder he's not going to have the
passing numbers but he's he's gonna
what's he got how many uh rushing
touchdowns make love has he got like 73
rushing touchdowns
paulie 71 career rushing touchdown all
right could he get to
let's say he gets to 85 or 90 rushing
touchdowns barry sanders had 99 now i
know he had a lot of yards but i just
wonder
could cam be
a hall of famer
when it's all done
i think the next five years are going to
answer that question if this is his last
stint in the nfl and this kind of
fizzles out in carolina this year and
cam doesn't play in 2022 23 24 25
maybe not but cam's not done i mean cam
looks excellent he stays in shape we
know how well he takes care of his body
his diet he's always talking about that
kind of stuff so you know physically
he's got some some tread left on those
tires so if cam continues to play into
2025 26 27 absolutely if this is it and
this kind of fizzles out and doesn't
work out in carolina for a second time
we may not see cam on the field again
carson palmer former nfl quarterback
heisman trophy winner at usc ever had
one of those moments that teddy
bridgewater had yesterday on the
interception where he made a business
decision to not make a tackle
i i have not had any of those uh i i've
seen it time and time again i mean
at the end of the day when when you're
down and you're losing you throw a pick
i always felt like i had to make the
tackle because i felt so bad for
throwing it i felt so bad that my
teammates around me were trying so hard
and trying to execute and i made the
mistake
we've seen some business decisions you
know now that they're 17 games you know
teddy's teddy's you know they've been
struggling they've been losing some
games over the last month and a half so
i can understand the business decision
but you just don't want that uh caught
on film because the eye in the sky never
lies and the eye in the sky always
catches business decisions and
unfortunately that one got caught okay
what's that going to be like when they
go
through film session today
yeah i mean that's that's one of those
ones where as you know you're sitting in
the front row all quarterbacks typically
sit in the front row of the meeting and
you just kind of slowly start dipping as
coach hits play and you kind of don't
want to everybody be looking at you but
you know and you're in the auditorium
coaches in front of you
all your teammates you can just feel
those eyeballs just closing in on you as
that's going on
you played in a thai game
right in arizona
i did yeah
what's that feeling like
well if if you're 0.8 it feels pretty
damn good uh it's just such an unknown
feeling uh if you're on eight we we did
it uh
on i believe a thursday night game
um against against seattle at home and
it's awful it when you're playing well
and you're in an inner division game
like i was that wasn't inner division
because it was detroit and pittsburgh
but
man it's a long plane ride home if if
you're detroit and you're so close to
your final win and the kicker's out
there for the game winner and
everybody's putting their helmets up and
getting ready to put a hat on celebrate
your first win and then he misses it and
you tie it's just so deflating
but the flip side is at least you didn't
lose and they were they were oh and
eight now they're one out oh eight and
one so that's better than on nine
we talked about cam getting incorporated
into the offense on short notice how did
the rams matthew stafford bring obj in
and how much do you expose him to with
tonight's game
well i think we're going to see a
handful of or or packages at least a
handful of plays but i think it's real
simple i mean the playbook is is this
thick and it's got you know 180 plays in
it obj here's 12. we need you to come in
on these 12 plays and he could be
absolutely decoy leroy they could be
actually designed plays where he's the
first or second read
but i absolutely expect to see him as
long as he's healthy i expect him to see
on the field
uh you know i just think shawn is so
smart and and i've heard obj is so smart
himself so giving him a simple package
of you know seven eight nine ten plays
just to get his feet wet maybe get the
ball in his hands once or twice on a
screen on a simple curl route uh i'm
excited to see him play and i'd be
shocked if he wasn't suited up playing
tonight okay so you just called him a
decoy leroy
decoy leroy
yeah
meaning that's that's the guy that he
knows every once in a while whatever
position you are you are supposed to
take a defender with you or hopefully
too maybe you're running a big deep post
route on the outside to clear out the
middle of the field for the receiver on
the opposite side coming into that zone
so decoy leroy there's just about one
guy that's decoy libra on every play in
the nfl
and you know
you know you're not getting the ball
i mean there's a 99.999
chance you're not getting the ball if
it's a scramble drill and something
happens in the pocket and all of a
sudden all hell breaks loose you can try
to find a way to get open but
guys know when they're decoy leeway they
know when they're clearing it out for
somebody else and opening up another
player good to talk to you as always we
appreciate your time carson thanks for
joining us
thanks dan carson palmer former nfl
quarterback and he's now a decoy leroy
now that he's not playing